l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
reconnu aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est du
bout des lèvres on va le voir qu'il y a
des preuves des preuves qui émergent
selon lesquelles la corée 19 pourraient
se transmettre par l'air c'est à dire en
aérosol le virus pourrait se propager
par ces micro gouttelettes le qui
demeure assez longtemps dans l'air ma
prochaine invitée fait partie des 239
scientifiques qui ont prévenu la
communauté médicale internationale
hier est évidemment l'om est caroline
duchesne on va sur université laval et
directrice du laboratoire de recherche
sur les bio aérosols madame chen bonsoir
en soit on sait déjà parlé au cours de
cette pandémie et la dernière fois je
crois c'est au moment où vous reveniez
d'une démarche des expertises sur le
terrain aller faire des prélèvements
justement sur les lieux mêmes où le
virus s'était propagé je veux savoir
pourquoi vous avez joint ses 238
scientifique pour interpeller la
communauté internationale sur la
possibilité que le virus se propage en
aérosol la preuve de la transmission est
pas encore complètement fait en fait les
élites les informations scientifiques
qu'on a eu des petites évidence la
raison pour laquelle la lettre a été
écrite pour laquelle j'ai accepté de lac
aux cygnes sites comme les autres
collègues aussi qu'on fait la même chose
c'est que depuis le début d'avoir des
mii les les gens en santé publique où
les médecins à maladies infectieuses ont
tendance à voir le problème un peu de
façon dichotomique c'est à dire des
microbes qui se transmet par l'air des
microbes qui se transmettent par les
surfaces bien que pas encore d'évidence
clair dans quelle situation se vit le
choix pourrait se transmettre par là il
ya plusieurs plusieurs virus et utilise
l'air comme voie alternative de
transmission on pense que c'est le cas
de la grippe parce que c'est le cas du
rhume des gastro entérites
cependant à cause du nombre de cas dans
le monde 2 d'envisager de contrôler la
ventilation afin de réduire cette course
sur l'eau de la transmission qui demeure
encore un peu mystérieux mais il ya
quelques codes santé déclinant des
restaurants trop haute ou là pourra
jouer un rôle
on pense quand même que si les autorités
règlement tout conseil le contrôle au
niveau de la ventilation donc un apport
d'air frais dollars filtré éviter la
circulation de l'air mais peut-être que
ça pourrait ajouter un outil
supplémentaire au contrôle du virus dans
d'une part des mis aussi importante que
celle là en même temps vous avez réussi
vous et les 238 à faire bouger l'om est
ce parce que même dans les articles hier
il ya quelques jours le oms continue de
dire il ya pas de preuve ya pas de
preuve et aujourd'hui on nous dit vous
avez entendu la porte parole de l'om est
des preuves maintenant émergent
quelle est la nature ou la fiabilité de
ses preuves qui émergent
je crois que c'est juste un changement
de paradigme en fait les gens réalisent
que des preuves solides
absents ne signifie pas qu'il n'y a pas
de risque c'est toujours en épidémie
épidémiologie ce soit des preuves
indirectes donc des modèles de
transmission puis on sait qu' il ya des
virus qui se retrouvent dans l'air sont
le démontrer notre équipe d'autres
équipes on a trouvé du virus dans l'air
de là à comprendre complètement le rôle
colère vont jouer c est encore
extrêmement floue mais faut être
réaliste pour la grippe ce n'est même
pas encore clair ça fait des années
qu'on l'ait dudit puis on comprend pas
encore clairement le rôle que jouent
l'air dans la transmission cependant
louer mais je pense commence à réaliser
que c'est une partie du mode de
transmission qu'on peut vraiment caché
ou coup pour coup vraiment ignoré alors
de ne serait-ce que dame médecin c'est
quand même un groupe louis a en même
temps c'est un grand principe de
précaution mais précisons une chose
parce que les gens sont sont pas
familiers avec le vocabulaire
scientifiques rattachés à ça depuis le
début on nous dit des gouttelettes
et quand on dit par l'air ou aérosols
sur c'est quoi
dites nous qui restent dans leur tissu
urbain les héros se ces sources c'est
que les gens ont tendance à voir soudan
deux familles de ceux qui restent à
l'arrêt ce qui tombe sur les surfaces
mais ce qu'on sait c'est que les
particules vont être dans tout le
spectre de grosseur de particules dont
il va en avant tout rester plus ou moins
longtemps
je pense qu'ils se changent aussi
mettons la vision de cette maladie le
sceqe récemment il ya des études quand
même majeurs qui ont été publiés qui
demande que le nez serait le site de
prédilection pour le virus donc
l'endroit dans le cas où nous avons de
plus de récepteurs pour l'infection se
serait d'emmener non pas dans le respire
à elle respire exactement a donc le ça
ouvre la porte aussi que les
gouttelettes un peu plus grosses qui
resteront suspension peut-être un peu
moins longtemps son lead-in alors 16 ans
d'emmener elle pourrait éventuellement
infecter les cellules nasale douze
histoires de la noce mis les gens qui
perdent
l'odorat et par la suite cause une
pneumonie plus par aspiration ce sont
des gens qui ont opposé cette hypothèse
est donc le virus a fait descendre le
poumon pour infecter vraiment donc ça
démontre un peu que le virus se plaint
de stratégie donc que c'est directement
des fois dans le monde quant au complet
par des petites particules ou par des
surfaces par la bouche par le nez mais
aussi par l'inhalation de particules un
peu plus grosse donc le terme aérosols
un des deux co signataire d hab deux
auteurs principaux leaders milton haut
depuis le tout début de la pandémie
il fait beaucoup la promotion du fait
que les particules aérosols qui sont
plus petites que 5 microns c'est les
particules et russell vraiment
extrêmement claires les personnes qui
seraient là dessus sauf que les autres
un petit peu plus grosse reste assez
longtemps patins pour être inhalées pour
peut-être avoir un impact fort bien que
touché au nez mais ça peut être
dépendamment de la ventilation ça peut
être plusieurs heures ça peut être
plusieurs minutes ça peut être
les particules peuvent rester là relate
de façon infinie donc à quelques pas et
ça vous arrive comme inspectrice
j'arrête tout de suite là parce que je
crois qu'on perd pas le fil de ces
passionnés ce qu'on nous dise que je
fais une heure avec vous alors les les
les airs peuvent rester en suspension
un bon bout de temps quelques minutes
quelques heures mais les micro micro
micro les petites la l'aérosol peuvent
rester longtemps
oui en fait les particules qu'on appelle
vraiment aérosols sont des particules
pour lesquels la gravité agir à peu près
pas donc finalement mené un petit peu
c'est pour ça aussi que c'est difficile
de bien comprendre même les petites
boules il est donc un peu plus gros
qu'un air eau sol mais un peu plus petit
qu'une grosse goutte qui va tomber sur
une surface se prépare notamment des
courants d'air ça peut rester dans l'air
quand même un peu longtemps qu'il ya des
gens ce qu'ils ont modélisé avec des
caméras ultra puissante on voit vraiment
les nuages de petites petites boutiques
donc en fait c'est ce que la ligue
demande à l'odm andalou msc de
reconnaître ce risque à lomé dans
certaines situations particulières et ce
qui est vraiment mis de l'avant dans la
lettre c'est les endroits avec beaucoup
de achalandage en plusieurs personnes
contacts prolongés et mauvaise
ventilation et on vient exactement à la
situation qu'on parlait des ch et celle
des la dernière fois où c'est un petit
peu ce qui se passait beaucoup de gens
malades
il ya un contact prolongé puis au pas de
ventilation dans plein d'endroits mais
qu'en est il de ce qu'on vit
actuellement parce qu'on le voit
beaucoup
aux etats unis le déconfinement les
plages parce que là c'est à l'extérieur
même les baril sous les terrasses des
gens ou les plages ici les gens cette
lutte il est ce que les aérosols ou les
gouttelettes reste malgré tout dans
l'air à l'extérieur c'est sûr que
l'extérieur il ya l'aspect dilution il
ya beaucoup plus de courants d'air du
vent un peu c'est certain que c'est tout
un gradient encore l'eau il ya un
gradient de risque quand on est à
l'intérieur le risque est plus grand
qu'on à l'extérieur le risque est plus
petit mais encore là aussi une
promiscuité des contacts étroits il est
possible d'avoir une transmission d'une
personne à l'autre si la personne est
malade c'est automatique
d'où l'importance de congas rôle de m
qu'est-ce qu'on recommande ses portes et
le mariage
donc ça peut arriver quand même à
l'extérieur mais dans certaines
situations ça va être plus important
oui parce qu'on s'inquiète d'eux on
l'entend dans le discours et banham
clank la mairesse a choisi d'imposer le
masque on va parler des comportements
tout à l'heure avec un scientifique
également imposé le masque on sent qu'à
québec on n'ose pas trop avec ce que
vous n'osez plus belle ou émettre
aujourd'hui ils vous parlez vous autres
de systèmes de ventilation pour évacuer
les gouttelettes c'est pas la
ventilation qui cause une mauvaise
ventilation qui pourrait causer le virus
je comprends bien une bonne ventilation
l'évêque exactement la ventilation c'est
toujours notre allié dans le cas des
maladies contagieuses donc on veut
sortir les virus d'art puisse jamais
allé au dollar qui recirculer on doit
filtrer l'air c'est la même chose pour à
peu près tous les agents qui ont pollué
l'air mais avec ce que vous nous dites
au fond on peut penser que québec qui
semble pas cher ou d'être l'auteur nous
dit on étudie on a l'impression que de
tarare d'aujourd'hui il avait le goût
d'annoncer le port du masque
monsieur legault plus prudent pas prêt
encore mai
au fond le masque ça fait partie des
protections pour tous on protège les
autres et on se protège sûr on a un
masque sur l'année on risque peu de
respirer les gouttelettes qui se
promènent la mois le masque plus est
utilisé pour protéger les autres quand
même sans doute une certaine efficacité
pour le porter aussi mais ça c'est
extrêmement variable de modèle à l'autre
sauf que ce qui est important c'est dans
les situations mettant où l'école
recommence où les gens sont délibérément
à l'intérieur dans des milieux fermés
mais de jouer un peu sur la ventilation
parce que le mince que lavage de mains
la distanciation je crois que ça
commence à être bien acquis puis l'aube
et peut-être qu'ils vont agir dans
encore une couche de sévérité je vous
dirai dans les recommandations avec le
masque pour tous
mais au delà de sousse qu'on croise et
que par exemple ça va être difficile à
piquer dans certaines situations par
exemple dans les écoles primaires par
exemple dans les gares de vie à ce
moment là on peut toujours se tourner
vers la ventilation pour encore mieux en
fait pour offrir un contrôle un petit
plus supplémentaire à une situation qui
peut d'ici là contrôlé dans le texte
dont j'ai la version anglaise ici c'est
je pense que c'est un exemple dans le
fond quand on se rend compte que des
événements majeurs pour lui peut-être vu
davantage aux états unis qu'ici des
événements majeurs pour se rend compte
après coup le kent grande propagation
je pense que le texte nous dit que les
aérosols de trace la route du virus ou
par aérosol
c'est la seule explication de cette
super contamination c'est un peu près du
patient et si comme ceux qui les voient
des veaux de contamination c'est comme
ça qu'elles sont souvent un peu et
lucide et c'est à 17 avec des études de
cas donc par exemple il va voir d'un
coup tu seras sans 2003 il y avait le
co2 building avec 300 personnes
contaminées où l'on est vraiment
démontré que la seule façon d'expliquer
que les gens s'étaient contaminés entre
eux c'était les courants d'air nos
building à l'autre dans des avions et
des bons exemples par exemple quelqu'un
qui a une qui malades qu une gastro par
exemple si un endroit comment les autres
personnes ont pu l'attraper alors des
fois on élimine les contacts on élimine
les bouclettes on voit baisser leurs
kilos transporté avec dans le code du
lakovic 19
c'est un peu la même chose j'ai eu
quelques situations dans la littérature
comme le restaurant dont je parlais tout
à l'heure où des gens est un fait et dit
par une table de face de gens qui
avaient la conduite sans le savoir
puis on peut partager d'objets on va
partager de salle debeyre vos parties
j'ai du temps c'est la seule façon
c'était des courants d'air qui ont été
modélisés qui aurait transporté
c'est vraiment des situations
particulières qui nous permettent
d'élucider cas par cas dans toutes les
éclosions
quelle est la voie principale de
transmission d'une personne à l'autre
dans ce groupe-là donc al yom et ont des
contacts étroits entre les personnes là
c'est évident on va se dire les gens
chez les mêmes objets comme dans les
bateaux de croisière selon le rapport du
cd si c'est pas l'air qui était
responsable c'est vraiment les contacts
entre les personnes parce qu'un couple
ils ont été isolés y avait pas de
corrélation entre le rien avec le
système ventilation et le fait qu'ils
ont frappé la côte dans le bateau de
croisière qui ont été abordés dans leur
chambre
donc c'est exactement comme suit les
gens procès d épidémiologie qui
regardent les explosions qui essaie de
voir les façons que les gens sont
rentrés en compte tels qu'un par rapport
à l'autre soit directement indirectement
ou pas par l'air dans ce que le bon
alors en terminant précaution précaution
aux précautions
l'absence de preuve absolue c'est pas
des scientifiques à savoir l'absence de
preuve n'est pas la preuve de l'absence
de tout est très famille nation c'est
tout à fait puis avec le nombre de
coquilles sur la terre en ce moment je
pense que même si ça représentait un sur
un million - sur 10000 points sur 100
déco par l'herbe ainsi on est capable
d'avoir encore un meilleur contrôle sur
la propagation en touchant cet aspect là
ben tant mieux ça vaut justin d un petit
peu le monde à passer à travers ce qu'un
petit pas de plus merci beaucoup
madame chen vous êtes universités des
grandes experte au pays dans le monde
sur la question des airs au sol pour le
fait je pense a dit pas de plus dans la
prévention ce soir avec vos explications
merci beaucoup